washington d.c president biden is trying
to gain support for his 1.9 trillion
dollar coronavirus relief package
this morning democratic leaders
introduced budget budget resolutions in
the house and the senate
that means they could pass president
biden's relief package with no support
from senate republicans
we are not going to dilute either or
delay the needs of the american people
are so demanding we need to think big
and we need to act quickly in an effort
to negotiate with republicans though
last night the president spent two hours
talking to a group of gop
senators both proposals from the
democrats and the republicans include
160 billion dollars for vaccinations and
testing
however the white house wants 400
dollars a week through september in
unemployment insurance
republicans won three hundred dollars a
week through june the biden
administration is also proposing
fourteen hundred dollar stimulus checks
while gop lawmakers propose
a thousand dollars for people in lower
income brackets